the Senate Armed Services Committee will
hold a hearing today to investigate
growing problems in the military housing
privatization program more than 200,000
homes on military bases across the
country are managed by private
contractors a year-long investigation by
the Reuters news agency turned up
dangerous living conditions today
senators will ask housing contractors
and Pentagon officials how they plan to
address the military family's complaints
about things like mold and water damage
chip Reid is on Capitol Hill with the
problems thousands say they are living
with this is just horrible listening to
what these families are going through
chip good morning yes good morning
Reuters says the Pentagon pays nearly
four billion dollars a year in rent to
private property management contractors
in nearly every state but much of that
housing is in disrepair and military
families have long said they feel they
have nowhere to turn to get help Josh
and lacy Sandin have lived in this house
at Fort Meade in Maryland for over two
years
at first I mean I looked clean
everything was blank white walls instead
of rent the Air Force pays a basic
housing allowance of nearly $2,200 a
month
directly to contractor Corvis military
living we started noticing issues from
almost the very beginning appliances
started breaking siding on their
eight-year old house was warped you can
see all along this wall and they
suspected mold growing on the floor and
walls was affecting their children's
health something their doctor hasn't
ruled out ear infections sinus cold it
was one after the other after the other
according to the EPA allergic reactions
to mold are common and exposure can
irritate the eyes skin nose throat and
lungs neighbors had a similar problem
mold and a burst pipe that left standing
water in their living room both families
say the response from Corvis was
extremely disappointing seems to be a
very long painstaking process to
actually try to get them to do anything
because they want to sweep it under the
rug a spokeswoman for Corvis declined to
discuss specific cases but acknowledged
the company had let down some residents
and said that while mold is a minor
problem they will be hiring an expert to
review the company's policies it felt
like people were screaming shannon
resident a Navy wife collected
complaints ahead of today's hearing from
more than seven thousand tenants across
the nation through her group the
military family advisory network they
shared stories of black mold of lead
paint rats roaches bats they're putting
their lives on the line to protect and
defend this nation and they're living in
squalor people don't have recourse and
so they don't have the opportunity to
withhold a rent check and often they
don't have the luxury of going to look
at housing before they move the Defense
Department's own inspector general cited
pervasive health and safety hazards at
housing facilities a Department of
Defense spokeswoman told CBS News that
the military and its housing partners
continue to work together to review
housing conditions and evaluate policies
and procedures I don't think there's a
lot of command support to address
housing issues crystal Cornwall will
testify before the Senate today after
experiencing issues with a contractor at
Camp Pendleton she helped organize a
Facebook group that now has nearly 2,000
members those are termites sharing
stories like this one viewed more than
200,000 times there is no way that any
kind of service member can do their job
when their family is not safe at home
the Pentagon told CBS News that military
families have the same rights as anyone
else but many families have told us and
Reuters that that simply is not true
they say that when they contact state
and local authorities they say they
can't even come on the property they
have no jurisdiction because the housing
is on federal land
Gail Murray chip thank you very much you
know I spent a lot of time growing up in
military housing not only here in the
United States but but overseas but this
is the most solemn vow how you take care
of your veterans in there
emily's and so they've got to fix this
problem which is why Congress is taking
it head-on
pretty shameful what we just saw thank
you chip